this is important story i want to talk
about dr dre got to pay his wife
300k a month for spousal
spousal support they're divorced 300k a
month
the kids are 24 and 20 or something like
that like the kids
out the house it's just 300k a month so
she can continue living the life
that she's a customer living how do you
guys feel about that
it's tricky with her because she's been
around since the jump right yeah
yeah son yeah no you know the other girl
they made the lifetime movie about
no she can't get nothing bro that abuse
victim got jack [ __ ]
she got some beats by dre literally
that's it but not she was around like
from the very beginning like he wrote
the letter to her like that whole thing
right
yeah she's been around for i mean
they've been there 24 years or something
like that like she's been around
she's been around for a while just the
idea of a monthly payment bothers me
if she wanted half okay you get half you
were there
now we're done you want out we're done
i don't keep paying you even if half is
more than what he's paying now
half to me is like all right you guys
built that together you could make the
argument whatever
now you had a clean up and the prenup
this is the agreement in the prenup
by the way so it's not like she's
getting more than what she deserved
exactly i should have prefaced that so
this is the agreement per the prenup and
i'm sure the prenup said something like
uh even if we do get divorced you have
to maintain my lifestyle up to a certain
extent
she was asking for two million a month
that's what it was when she had that
initial like
ten fifteen thousand dollars a month for
laundry or something dumb no the charity
hundred ten thousand dollars a month or
hundred thousand dollars a month for
charity i think akash goes
[ __ ] your charity yeah that's what
she's about to say you charity [ __ ]
yeah but there's no that's like her
attorneys like that's them playing this
like legal game
like you asked for money two million
you're going to settle at 300k
yeah but and basically i think uh dr dre
won the suit which makes it go down to
200 000.
so he's worth so much that three million
a year is
it's not much for him and it's actually
three million a year isn't the craziest
settlement i've ever heard of
just the idea of spousal support yeah it
seems you are not my spouse yes
legally we have dissolved that term from
you you want half
all right we can have the whole eddie
murphy joke half etcetera fine but like
fine you guys built that together
i got to keep paying you when you leave
but if that's in the prenup like bro you
agreed
it i think there's another thing that
also goes with it i understand your
point like
i think on some people might be
digesting your [ __ ] bad because you're
basically saying
give her half if she was there from the
jump but they had the prenup
so this is the agreement based on the
yeah that's what you got to do that's
fine exactly so it's fair because that's
what they agreed on
yes we see it seems like an egregious
amount of money to just give somebody
that you're not even [ __ ] or not even
with or not even taking care of your
kids because they're i think 20 and 24
right but that being said if you're
there from the jump
yeah and apparently the sorry but if
you're there from the jump and like
you gave up your life to support what he
was doing
and raise the kids i
i think they deserve it i know it sounds
crazy but if you give up
what your passion is and you give up the
thing that can make money for you
like if you give up your career let's
say she was gonna be a lawyer or some
[ __ ]
and then they basically had a
conversation she's like listen i'm gonna
take care of these kids
but i need some assurances from you that
i'm not gonna give up my career my way
of feeding myself
and then if it doesn't work out between
us i'm done what's interesting about
that is
i think i agree with you but you said
it's so cocky i i'm out
i really am just like what dreams did
you have [ __ ] what you talking about
you had a three million dollar your
dream [ __ ] hey you could keep dreaming
[ __ ] you talking about it wasn't to
happen you weren't going to make it
i wonder if they could be a lawyer i
wonder if they take the average
like the pa let's say um to calculate
his income they take like the average of
like the last three years
and i think it was just bad timing yeah
because if you it
if the year when that beats by dre
situation happened
his income looks crazy yeah but right
now
he's back to a normal yeah i'm sure he's
still making great money but not yeah
like that so if that year was calculated
in averaging his income but the
attorneys know that like the attorneys
are doing
like i'm assuming all the legal [ __ ]
like they've been trying to file for
divorce for like 10 years and
they told them the best time yeah the
attorneys like wait put serve the papers
on this day
hide this money over here put this money
in a
in a charity or this money and a like
what are those things called uh
like a foundation or something yeah yeah
yeah shell company etc like they know
listen when you get divorced and you're
rich that should take two years before
you even go yo we're getting divorced
yeah like you're moving so many things
around so your wife don't get it
yeah and she's doing [ __ ] to try to get
what she's gotta get like yeah it's all
it's all again
and that's why it's kind of wild because
i think he accused her of like stealing
money
remember this was happening early and i
didn't even think about this early on
like i'm i'm thinking they're happily
married and all of a sudden she's
conniving and trying to like take money
out of the accounts and like put in her
account
right but this whole time i'm sure she's
like oh this [ __ ] think he's
gonna hide all our money
before the divorce and then i ain't
gonna get [ __ ]
[ __ ] you i'm gonna hide some money too
she also accused him of moving money
around oh she did yeah see i didn't see
that because i only look at things
through the men's perspective
we're always right interesting but yeah
and apparently her agreement is in place
until she remarries or enters into a new
domestic partnership
which she will never do further court or
until
further order of the claim and that's
the other thing that is i do find
annoying is you find guys that aren't dr
dre income that pay spousal support
who the wife will have a living
boyfriend
and be like well i'm not getting married
because then i lose this free check yeah
yeah yeah bro you know how much that's
why
you know she gotta love a man to not get
paid 300 000
a month to do nothing yeah like if you
[ __ ] some dude on the side
like you can't make it official or else
you lose three hundred thousand dollars
he gotta be rich enough to say [ __ ] that
we don't need his money very few guys
are there
dre wants the monthly payment he doesn't
want to give her a half
yeah you give her a half like he's
giving her a half a million half a
billion dollars
yes i almost think even then as a rule
you get half if you're married and
spousal support in the thing
even if it costs a guy more money listen
i was actually thinking
you make decisions together she's a part
of this if you got a wife that's like
that you trust intellectually probably
that's why you married her yeah all
right let's do this together let's build
it
we lost it i know i did more but let's
just get this over with you that is the
dumbest thing he's ever said
but you're a numbers man yeah i know a
month
instead of half a million i'm not a
numbers man i'm a man of principles
clearly i'm a man of principle clearly
not principle
because i'm not that good with money so
half of every principle half of all the
investments
you're going to take half yo we're out
we're done and if you're
if you're that rich you're probably
still fine we just have to be honest how
do you get half the house
hey we sell that who wants to live in
this [ __ ] hateful ass house where we
[ __ ] the last time
you know we're talking you want them
shitty ass of like say 40 million
or 500 million i'm not talking about
what he should do i'm saying what the
law should be